this report is from khq in washington um
local news affiliate down there it says
there's no question that shane goldsby
assaulted and killed robert munger
inside the airway heights correctional
center
the question is why were they assigned
to live together in the same prison cell
monger a 70 year old convicted child
rapist
died after goldsby hit monger in the
face and head around hunt
about 14 times stomped on his head at
least four times
and kicked a couple more times before
walking away and being taken into
custody by
correction guards uh munger was
convicted on multiple child molestation
charges
in 2019 he was sentenced to 43 years in
prison
um sex offenders are considered marked
men and state prisons nationwide like in
california where sex offenders are
killed in prison at a rate that is
double the national average
um what about the risk though when a sex
offender is put in the same cell
with their victim's older brother now
this is the part
that is hard to believe but this is
what's being reported and there are some
sources for it
it says goldsby um goldsby himself also
cindy elliott who's the mother
of um the mother of gold's been also the
mother of the child that was reportedly
victimized by monger
and an anonymous tipster said that
monger raped goldsby's little sister
who was still a minor the reporter says
i talked to goldsby who is currently
in uh the jail facing a new charge
pretend premeditated murder and then he
goes on he talks about he says
what he claims and they've got
apparently three sources and this has
now been reported by multiple media
outlets
that um shane goldsby was
put in a prison cell with this monger
guy
and munger not only a serial child
rapist that we know for sure
convicted of that but apparently
according to his reports
he he actually raped goldsby's little
sister and
told him about it monger the rapist told
goldsby and started taunting him
with details of his little sister's rape
and uh also apparently reportedly
goldsby went to the prison officials
and he went through the process of
trying to get transferred to a new cell
and they wouldn't transfer him
and finally he says he just snapped and
he had enough of it and he
beat the guy to death and now he's
getting
25 years in prison for that
um
this is sort of an easy case for me to
adjudicate personally because
even without the detail of this guy
raping
goldsby's little sister even taking that
aside
i wouldn't give him 25 years in prison
even if he was just sort of generally
angry
and upset that this man is a serial
child rapist
i'm not giving you 25 years in prison
for that
i mean if anything i'm thinking about an
early release
because of that and i and i
again this is that is also not a joke i
actually i kind of mean that sincerely i
this is wine if you don't like it you
say well we can't have vigilante
killings and stuff like that in prison
and i mean and you're right from
a reasonable perspective you can't have
that for the sake of the
of um of the safety of everyone in the
prison not
not the child rapist but everyone
including the prison guards you can't
just
you know allow peop allow the inmates to
kill each other
willy-nilly in the prison yard but um
if if we're saying that
child rapists are so heinous
and such absolute monstrous scumbags
that you can't even put them around
other scumbags
you can't even put them around murderers
and people that have done
other horrible things but not that
horrible
like even those people don't want to be
around someone like that then i think
that tells us that this is the kind of
crime
where if you commit that we should
probably rather than leaving
the inmates to take care of it probably
the state should take care of it
you see you lock that person in in a
cell on death row
and then you take care of them that way
there should be that should be an
execution
i think that's a that's a pretty good
way to judge these things
if it's the kind of crime where we
cannot put you in with general
population because they would be so
disgusted by
you that they wouldn't be able to stop
themselves from killing you
then probably might not work this way
every time depends what the crime is
that's a pretty good indication that you
should be eligible for death row
it is crazy to me that
even in states where we still have
capital punishment
in no state that i'm aware of can you be
executed
for simply raping a child
that's the idea well if you just do that
then we're not going to execute you you
have to you have to also kill someone
as long as you haven't killed anyone
then you're not going to be eligible for
for death row
so you could have someone who murdered
one person
they they go on death row i'm fine with
that
um and then you could have someone else
who
let's say raped 40 kids no death row for
them
because everyone physically survived it
emotionally mentally psychologically is
another story but physically everyone
survived it
even if barely and that's not going to
be eligible for death row that to me
doesn't make any sense there's no
justice in that whatsoever
then you add in the detail about his
sister here's what i'll say
the person who should be if we're given
25 years to anybody it should be the
prison officials responsible
for putting this poor guy in a cell with
the the monster who raped his sister
that's the person we give 25 years to
for shane goldsby you know
at worst here's what i at at worst if
you feel like you have to do something
you give them
you give give them a slap on the wrist
maybe a literal slap on the wrist you
say hey
don't do that don't kill child rapists
we don't do that here no no no
then send him about his day listen
hit that subscribe button right now do
it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated